great that's great to be here um as a
wrapping up Stanford PhD right now
myself it's a it's fun that I've watched
a number of these colloquia from my own
laptop and to be giving one now here is
a great honor opportunity so I'm at
Braden here on caucus I said I guess I'm
a fourth year PhD student I'm finishing
up work my research in general has been
on raising the sort of the abstraction
level for supervision can we allow
higher and higher level inputs for
training machine learning models make it
more accessible quicker to program and
and often higher quality so that we'll
be presenting in computer science yep
advice by Chris Rea so then the name of
the this project is babble babble
well it'll become evident why as we move
forward so to set some context for this
work in most real-world machine learning
applications today the the quality
bottleneck is not finding the right
model like state-of-the-art models
almost always a few literally a few
lines of code and you can import it and
whether it's a ResNet and pi torch or
you know bert recently open sourced it's
not hard to get the best models and
hardware similarly not hard a few lines
of code a few minutes you've spun up a
whole rack of GPUs on AWS so far more
often the the actual bottleneck when it
comes to getting quality item numbers on
a new application is getting training
data getting training data that's
specific to your particular application
and there's rarely a substitute for that
that you can just import or use off the
shelf so let's consider for a moment
than where these data sets usually come
from throughout this presentation I'll
use this running example where we have a
relation extraction task so we've got
sentences from the news with two
individuals highlighted and our job is
to classify are they married or are they
not I'm pretty easy for us to understand
as humans so the typical approach for
tasks like this is that a human will go
through these examples one-by-one take a
look at it digest the sentence
understand what's going on make an
assessment on whether or not the people
are married and then you know click yes
or no
give us one single bit of information or
our label but this this feels like a bit
of a waste because after they've spent
all this effort digesting understanding
coming up with a reason for why it's
true or false we're at the end of the
day boiling that down to a single bit
information so you know the the majority
of the time is spent doing things that
we don't actually get to harness so
given that the user has already gone
through this effort it'd be nice if we
could collect a richer form of
supervision from the user for example if
we could get the reason why they labeled
it the way that they did then this would
give us a more flexible input that could
potentially be applied to other examples
and give ourselves a higher bandwidth
way of getting the supervision from the
head of the user into the model so we
can view each of these explanations that
we collect from a user as they label as
encoding a heuristic for how you might
label new examples so for instance the
explanation that we got on the previous
page from a totally different example
could also apply to these three examples
where we see that you know that that
heuristic also applies and could be used
to to apply these labels here but we get
these ones for free a human didn't have
to look at these we just reused the
humans idea and applied it so you can
imagine that if we had enough of these
labeling heuristics provided by you say
and gave them to another human along
with a bunch of unlabeled data they
could make a training set for you
approximately of course not not quite
the same as if you've done it yourself
but they could use a lot of your same
intuitions to automatically generate a
training set for you and hand it back to
you but of course we're not interested
in I'm just doing crowdsourcing where I
actually wanted now to take your
heuristics and give them to a computer
to label a bunch of unlabeled data for
you and that's what this project is all
about so the big idea here is that we're
not going to collect labels from humans
we're gonna collect labeling heuristics
in the form of natural language
explanations and that's what we use to
automatically generate large training
sets that can then train classifiers for
the task that you care about so to be
concrete that the name of our system is
babble babble and it is a framework for
generating large training sets from
natural language explanations and
unlabeled data very importantly all
components of this framework work
without labeled data so this is the
purpose of this is to create your
labeled training sets not consume it and
we've stuck very carefully to that in
the design of this system and our main
quantitative results here that I'll go
through more thoroughly in the end is
that we found across three different
domains when we're real
applications that you can achieve the
same classifier quality using far far
fewer user inputs usually ranging from 5
to 100 times fewer user inputs when
we're collecting explanations from you
instead of just labels so I will take a
look closer look now at the individual
components of the babble a bowl
framework as I mentioned the inputs are
unlabeled examples and explanations that
are provided by the user and then the
first component now is a semantic parser
so the purpose of a semantic parser is
to convert our labeling heuristics um or
I guess the purpose of semantic parsers
in general is to convert some in a loose
form often text into a more discreet you
know machine readable form something
that can be structured in our case we're
gonna be converting these explanations
into labeling functions and a labeling
function for us is just a simple Python
function that takes in an example X and
outputs a label in this case 1 or true
or can abstain if it's not certain
either way on calling this true or false
so to actually create our parses we
start with an input sentence like this
and a static set of oh sorry
yes yeah so we start with the the
explanation label false because x and y
are the same person if we're referring
to our people as x and y in the sentence
and then we have these substitution
rules here in the box
and those substitution rules can be used
to map you know tokens to other
higher-level tokens sometimes in
combination so this is basically a
context-free grammar if you remember
from from your basic computer science
classes and we basically map from from
the input into a number of different
potential parse trees we're essentially
going to find with all the possible ways
that this input could be interpreted as
a valid labeling function and our
labeling functions again will always
take this form of return some label if
the condition you scribed is met
otherwise abstain and are the semantic
parts that we used had a pretty
primitive grammar very simple actually
just kind of a subset of Python plus and
helper functions so we have logic in
comparison officer operators less than
greater than and ORS etc string matching
things like looking at the case or sub
strings or starts with
with any art tags we just took an
off-the-shelf tagger that tagged you
know certain tokens as being a person or
location so you could refer to those
sets and mapping and relative
positioning so X came before Y or X is
within three words of Y things like that
so really quite simple when it comes
right down to it and one way in which
our parts are though is unique from your
typical semantic parser is that
typically you're trying to find the the
best parse for an input example you're
trying to find the correct
interpretation from your loose input
into a discreet and concrete output but
in our framework we don't actually care
so much about the quality of the
semantic parser except for the way in
which it affects our overall system so
actually we don't really want the
correct parts we just want useful parses
often that will be the correct parts but
we're not so concerned with that so will
actually allow our semantic parser to
output multiple potential labeling
functions in fact any any possible parse
that comes out to be a valid looking
labeling function we will keep and pass
on downstream and that's where we'll
deal with the ambiguity of figuring out
what was actually intended or how these
could be used to help us so that was our
first component is to map these
explanations into discrete functions for
us the second component is a filter Bank
so you know once again do I gets to
dysgraphic lis
we have explanations coming in those go
through our semantic parser and we end
up with generally more possible
candidate labeling functions than we had
explanations and now the filter banks
job is to remove as many of these as we
can and we're gonna do that by using
some common-sense heuristics basically
very lightweight to run but rules that
we can use for figuring out which of
these labeling functions are clearly not
going to be helpful for our use case and
we have two types of filters that we use
the semantics semantics filter and a
pragmatics filter so the semantics
filters job is to recognize when a
labeling function clearly could not be
the correct interpretation of what you
what we're trying to express so natural
language is inherently ambiguous and
things like you know this explanation
where it says that the words his wife
are right before person - there's a
chance that we could confuse right
before as meaning immediately before or
maybe like to the right of because right
can have both meaning
so it's possible that we end up with two
candidate labeling functions both with
slightly different meanings but we know
that this explanation came with example
x1 so when we apply these parses to x1
one of them abstains on its own example
so clearly we messed something up
clearly this is not the heuristic you
intended otherwise you wouldn't have
given us you know that explanation with
that example so in this case it fails
our semantic filter and we can toss that
example on the left out the other type
of filter is a pragmatic filter and this
filter actually doesn't care what you
intended it's job is just to remove
things that we can tell just by looking
at the way it labels our unlabeled data
are not going to be of high value so for
example some of our parses end up
labeling all examples in the data set
true or all false or abstain on
everything and that's not going to help
us make a good classifier so we can toss
that other times we end up with multiple
labeling functions that have the same
signature and they may actually be
logically equivalent we just went
through a different parse tree to get
them or they might just be so similar
technically different but so similar on
our training data
our unlabeled data set that it never
makes a practical difference in which
case we don't need both so we can toss
one and not feel bad about it and then
the last component once we've filtered
down our labeling functions is to to
aggregate their their outputs their
votes so we take the labeling functions
that have survived the filter bank apply
those to our unlabeled data and we end
up with this matrix which we'll call a
label matrix we have our labeling
functions on the left our data points
across the top and then the dots show
what vote they output for that example
and what we want is then to aggregate
these in some way such that we now have
your typical training data set X's and
Y's because our labeling functions are
automatic they're heuristic they're not
from a human they also aren't going to
have perfect accuracy they're not as
accurate as you are but say we have you
know 20 70 percent accurate labeling
functions you can see that pretty
quickly by the time we aggregate the
results we could do a pretty good job of
getting the right labels and some
percentage of the time certainly enough
to at least you know learn from and
you'll see down down the in future
slides how well that works so when it
comes to actually combining these
labeling functions you could do
something very simple and I Eve like
majority vote so in each column look at
how many positive votes I have how many
negative votes I have and and choose the
majority label and that works
but you know pretty well in a lot of
cases but you can often do better then
when we consider that there there may be
other interesting phenomena going on in
our data so sometimes you have labeling
functions that are very highly
correlated they might not be independent
and in that case we probably don't want
to count their votes as you know equally
valid is if we have some other totally
different source I'm telling us that yes
this is true or no it's false
there's also potentially high conflict
so this labeling function for seems to
be disagreeing with everyone so there's
a good chance that it's just a lower
accuracy labeling function and we
shouldn't count its vote as much as the
others and then lately in five function
five you can see is low coverage but
potentially very high accuracy so
there's lots of these interests in
different ways that these labeling
functions can interact you can majority
vote it it's simple
naive but you know as with a lot of
simple heuristics works decently but if
we go ahead and factor in these things
there's actually ways for us to do even
better we can model the accuracies and
correlations and then get much more
intelligent aggregated labels so the way
we do this is with a technique that was
not the focus of this paper it's part of
my other research a technique called
data programming where again in an
unsupervised way using no label data we
can provably recover the accuracies of
your labeling functions given that
they've labeled enough raw data and then
that ends up giving us a fair boost in
terms of overall quality so if you want
to find details on that technique you
can go to snorkelled at stanford.edu and
find em all of our work on data
programming but the I guess the
important thing to know signature wise
is just that at the end of this label
aggregation process we now have a single
label for each example which came from
combining all the labeling functions
you've written via natural language
explanations so now that we have our
training set the final step then is you
know we want to train a classifier now
we'll train that classifier but it's a
fair question to ask if my label
aggregator takes in unlabeled data
points and outputs labels isn't that a
classifier why do I need to train
another one and it's it's a pretty cool
reason why and we get a boost from doing
this so the motivation for this is
similar to distant supervision if you're
familiar with that technique but
basically our labeling functions don't
necessarily have perfect coverage a lot
of the time they're abstaining because
it's a fairly specific rule targeting a
particular keyword or a particular
you know currents or phrase or pattern
and so you know we may end up only
labeling 30% of our data or a lot of our
labels may end up having only one vote
from a Leyland function which is not
very dense not very informative and we
would end up having a huge number of
points that we can't actually vote on
but if we instead make a training set
using those labeling functions and then
use that to train another classifier
that has a much larger feature set we
can actually end up finding other
relevant signals that you never
specified but which are highly
correlated with the tasks that we care
about and we can do much better so
here's an example of that one of our
tasks was identifying chemicals that
cause certain diseases and the labeling
functions the explanations written by
the user included looking for words like
treats causes induces prevents which you
know are very reasonable valid signals
but then when we trained our second
classifier using the probabilistic
labels produced by our label aggregator
we found that some of the highest
highest weighted features were these
trigrams could produce and support
diagnosis of which to a human again
makes a lot of sense we never specified
those but because we now have a larger
feature set to draw on as we train our
second classifier we can take advantage
of those and then in practice that ends
up giving us a significant boost across
our three applications we found it was a
10 percent improvement or 4.3 f-1 points
on average and there's a number of other
reasons why you might want to do this as
well including sometimes you can
supervise over rather expensive things
to calculate using you know big
expensive offline models or heuristics
or aggregated statistics over time and
then you can transfer them to an edge
model that's just you know a simple
lightweight logistic regression or
something so a lot of cool reasons for
this again it's explored more and my
other work at that snorkelled at
stanford.edu but this is part of a
necessary part of the pipeline so I'll
show you now some of our experiments and
their results and the datasets that we
evaluated on where first the spouse
example which I showed you on the first
slide this is looking at news articles
two people tagged say whether they're
married or not the second it will call
the disease tasks and that's what I just
showed you in the previous slide where
we want to say did this chemical cause
that disease this is from biomedical
literature and the third one is also a
biomedical focus
and this was in conjunction with a
start-up in the area called Occam's
razor that's targeting Parkinson's
disease and gathering all the
information out in the public space
about that so here we were trying to
identify interacting protein kinase
pairs and the fortunate thing about this
is you couldn't just whip up a
Mechanical Turk job and have random
people on the internet label this task
for you it required a domain expert but
because we now have a way of magnifying
a single domain experts abilities and
knowledge since they can provide us with
20 labeling functions and do pretty well
as opposed to having the label thousands
of individual data points we can tackle
domains like this really quite quickly
so the the main result I guess that I
previewed for you earlier is shown here
in this table and that is that we took
30 labeling functions for each of these
domains and trained a classifier with
the the resulting labelled data set that
they created and then we compared that
to how many individual manual one-by-one
labels we had to collect to get the same
quality and so here in the second column
you can see that the classifier quality
and then you know always 30 explanations
used versus how many traditional labels
and it ends up being a fairly large
coefficient it varies by domain of
course depending on a variety of factors
the quality of the labeling functions
and the difficulty of the task but we go
from five to a hundred times gained them
in terms of how many inputs are actually
required from the human to get the same
quality which is pretty exciting that we
found and part of the reason why this
works is because each labeling function
that you're providing is actually giving
us many labels it puts us in this
convenient situation now where the
quality of your classifier is dependent
on the amount of raw unlabeled data that
you have not the amount of labeled data
that you have and typically I mean for a
lot of companies and organizations you
have a lot of raw data the hard part is
going through and one by one saying
true-false true-false
now instead we're doing this in bulk
we're saying you're all a little true
Theo you're all little foster you know
moving them in big chunks such that we
don't have to neat piles at the end of
the day but we have a pretty nice you
know a good sense of where everything
should be when we go to actually train
so you can see here we increase the
number of unlabeled
examples without requiring any
additional user inputs this is with a
static set of LFS and quality on all
three tasks goes up from 8 points on the
disease task to over 30 on the spouse
task them which again is pretty neat and
applies to so many domains where you
require a certain expertise to label
examples and it's just not practical to
do it all one by one
we also took a look then at some
ablation studies looking at how
important each of the individual
components of our system are so this is
looking at the filter Bank and it turns
out that our very simple set of
pragmatic and semantic filters which are
extremely quick to run ends up removing
almost 97% of the generated incorrect
parses the ones that aren't actually
exactly what the user intended which was
a little bit surprising to us at first
because we remember just throwing in the
kitchen sink here like any valid parts
that it produced where we're passing on
downstream but when you consider that
for a labeling function to make it
through it needs to you know be based on
the text based on the natural
explanation in some way and then it
needs to correctly label its own example
and not label identically to any other
existing examples it actually makes
sense that it really has to run the
gamut to make it through so you know
we're able to remove almost all of the
bad ones
so without our filter Bank we have a 15
F one point drop we lose the signal in
the noise but with it which again has
very little cost we do quite well we
also considered you know would we do
better if we had a perfect semantic
parser so we took the 9 D labeling
functions for our three tasks I'm 30
each and translated them by hand to
wrote out the corresponding Python
function for each of them and saw if we
do any better and the answer was not
really partly that's because our filter
Bank is so good but also the way that we
combine these labeling functions we
expect them to be noisy we're going to
learn their accuracies internally anyway
and down weight them and up weight them
accordingly so it's a pretty noise
tolerant framework which is cool because
you know typically a semantic parser
you'll be training with a whole separate
data set and as you change domains
you'll need to retrain it from scratch
to learn how it should map the new words
in your new domain to particular symbols
whereas this simple rule based parser is
using basic primitives that apply
across all domains for these relation
extraction tasks so it's there's there's
no overhead to applying this to some new
domain immediately right off the shelf
but because this is not a sales pitch
this is a research talk I will tell you
also the limitations of this that we
discovered so looking at the
explanations that user eyes are inclined
to naturally give often we do end up
with something you know quite usable but
occasionally there are higher level you
know concepts that they'd like to refer
to so in this case you know the human
says it sounds like they're probably
coworkers they didn't say the word
coworkers occurs you know within such a
distance or you know I see this phrase
as well as this phrase they're referring
to some real-world concept that our
partial doesn't know about and that in
that case we won't come up with any
valid parses or we will and they'll get
filtered out but but we can't use that
so fortunately explanations are are
quite lightweight when we measured how
long it took relatively to collect
explanations versus individual points
and it was about two times as long which
was lower than we expected we thought
it'd take a lot longer because you're
writing a full explanation as opposed to
just saying yes or no but turns out that
as our intuition suggests on that
earlier slide most of your time is spent
understanding the example not actually
clicking yes or no we're typing your
explanation so anyway I guess that
points out that it's we lose some
signals by not being able to capture
this higher-level stuff but it's not a
huge cost we can just collect more
examples that we can parse and use those
but I do think it's an interesting you
know additional research question how
you might use maybe some other types of
models such as maybe a question
answering model or an open information
extraction model to let the user specify
higher-level concepts like for our
spouse example they could say you know
if affection when I live together then
they probably are also married or if
they have a kid together they probably
are married and you could use some pre
training model on some other large
corpus like squad or something to come
up with these noisy labels and use those
so anyway interesting future directions
certainly here on how you could accept
even more broader types of signal
there's also some related work that we
compared to in our paper one is there
was a paper that came out a pretty
similar time to ours to just a couple
months before where they jointly trained
a semantic part
in a classifier so they were trying to
make their classifier higher quality and
they used its outputs directly as
features so that's that top thing and
that's basically a one model setup and
this actually does pretty well because
you are essentially hand designing
features for your task which is what we
has been the the mode of operation and
machine learning for years before deep
learning representation learning came
along and replaced the feature
engineering stage but we as I mentioned
before find a boost by using these not
as features but as labels for training
than a new model that has a larger
feature set and our boost was four and a
half f1 points in this case which was
10% I believe there's also other related
work in terms of approaches for getting
more bang for your buck for each label
that you collect so the most common
theme is what I call highlighting
approaches where you'll basically mark
you know the most relevant part of the
input the thing that you know um was it
was most had the largest effect on you
giving the label that you did but
there's a number of reasons why we want
to stick with natural language instead
one of these is that some patterns some
things you'd like to express can't be
done with highlighting like how do you
highlight the absence of a word or how
do you highlight you know um it matters
that this or that word occurs but not
necessarily both but I needed at least
one of them you can express this in
language but not necessarily with with a
highlighter or annotation like that
there's also a more direct credit
assignment so in this example if you
highlighted the words his wife we don't
necessarily know why his wife is
important is it because those words are
always important or they're only
important when they come right before
person to or only when they occur in a
sentence with Tom Brady there's we don't
have that direct credit assignment like
we do with natural language and then
finally when we use language you don't
actually have to assign a feature set a
priori because you're not labeling
features you're labeling examples and we
can use those to train any arbitrary
model so if they come out with the new
state of the art model tomorrow and you
want to use that you can reuse your
labels once again with that new feature
set without any loss of information or
effort so to summarize them there is
this growing need for training data to
feed our data hungry models the deep
learning models that can do a fantastic
job if you have enough data to feed them
and labeling in a traditional way leaves
a lot of supervision on the table that
goes unused and we'd like to harness
more of that and we found that by
collecting labeling heuristics in this
case in the form of natural language
explanations rather than collecting
labels we can much more efficiently
generate a large label training set for
the tasks that you care about and then
third with this approach we have the the
very convenient effect that your
training set size and therefore often
your classifier quality correlates with
the amount of unlabeled data that you
have access to rather than the amount of
labeled data which means for a lot of
applications that you can see much
larger gains than if you tried to and
you know label the same amount of their
label data with the same amount of time
but doing it by hand one example at a
time so the the code for this project is
available open source we have some
demonstrations as well where you can try
typing in your own explanations and see
how you do I'm at on github at that URL
and thank you very much for listening
thank you
[Applause]